avant Alou imagined his post university
future would be quite different now
he's lucky he'll sell two mobile phones
a day earning the equivalent of about 3
euros
despite graduating with a Business
Administration degree four years ago and
countless job applications he is still
an employed Alvin says the frustration
among young people here is palpable and
growing he's worried that it could tip
into violence
I remain hungry with a feature to come
then to have any disturbance II I know
what it takes to have uprising and to
beat at this level we go with a brassy
you don't have no peace your left is
highly at risk Liberia civil wars began
in 1989 and finally ended in 2003 but
this West African nations economy has
hardly grown since then you don't have
to compromise people give them fake
promises to see oh I will create 100
thousands of job well you know it's not
available or is not possible to do these
added things that they do need to be
real and tangible so that we have
confidence in them you seen there
Solomon pay is trying to get the
students and education and some hope but
as a business teacher he knows very well
that the same promises of jobs were made
during the election six years ago in his
opinion Lobby areas politicians have
failed to undertake the necessary
economic reforms every year the
university in my Bureau increase the
number of graduates but yet somebody got
a sitting room so one of the meetings
that I feed are gone as you do look at
the educational sector and the nesting
Britain investors one of the first ones
come those the economy open for Alvin
talut it has not been a good day so far
he hasn't sold a single phone he takes a
short ten-minute break at lunchtime he
hopes the tense election atmosphere will
soon be over and then business might
pick up again
you